thoughtful game plan probably summer
sandals and converse on sale and maybe
lingerie hi my name is Joyce BuzzFeed
gave me $200 that I can't spend so today
we're bringing two senior citizens and
whoever spent $100 each in under an hour
BuzzFeed gave me $100 and you only have
one hour to spend all the money and we
can't keep any of the change I got it
what's your game plan probably summer
sandals and converse on sale and maybe
lingerie
there's just a lot to choose from and
maybe they got sales going on how about
hands-free headset okay so she's about
to get the air bod yeah I also saw some
wind spinner
I don't know they've got beautiful stuff
okay do you feel confident that you can
spin all of them oh that's no problem
okay 100 dollars goes like that so do
you think you can get all of that for a
hundred bucks no but I know I'll spend
it all look what I am I gonna give
Leggett a yard I got a little travel
purse this is an RFID thing so you can
put your credit cards in here nobody's
gonna scan you summer sandals at a great
price ISOs awesome oh my God look how
cute so what kind of function are you
wearing these sandals - alright you know
what I'm gonna wear them to karaoke with
you honey yeah let's go karaoke stands
you and away
yeah cried for so long now we're going
for some gloves rubber gloves go go go
let's spin more and here we go there's
two things actually do you sound like a
little card like a gift card for coffee
you know what I love a good finesse get
that gift card I got a gift card for $10
for someone special my son I think yeah
he's got a son in the hospital with
prostate cancer and on a week from
Thursday they're gonna announce that
he's completely cured we are so happy
and filled with joy you know this is
also seem fun and like giving back but
it was actually like something that's
positive and we're able to celebrate it
by giving a hundred bucks we're so happy
yeah no this is a great thing it was
really good
check this out I know rubber gloves the
reality is the cheapy ones you get at
the grocery store lasts for like five or
six times now we've got the dryer
buddies so the drone your buddies help
move your clothes around in there well
the person was a special treat for me
okay here we go irresponsible yeah what
I want starts at $159 no thank you
I'm gonna get a movie pass I know where
we're going we're going right over there
we are going to the spinner forty even a
thirty five dollar gift pass to these
movies now we can see The Avengers a
second time a dog's journey looks good
detective two caught you I don't know
I'm not a fit okay
Oh
whoa you're right I got 750 left seven
how much do I have left to spend okay
I'll get different cheaper earrings her
time is running out so we're gonna let
him make this last purchase and then
let's see if she spent all the money I
got some cool stuff I had seven dollars
left
I got a fruit and cheese and then I have
a dollar 50 left so I'm gonna run back
in and throw the rest of the money in
the tip jar so now I'm at $100 so you
went over about four yeah I paid the
extra four dollars my own which was
nothing it really was we're gonna party
in the future yeah we have a plan how
has this whole experience been for you I
have to really kind of think about what
could I get the most of what I can use
again and then it'll have the memory of
being with you today I want to go to the
club I heard something about karaoke yes
oh that would be
[Music]
Amazing Grace how sweet the sound that
saved a wretch like me